hey guys you know in this day and age
that we live in Christian men need to
stand on God's word and believe in it
trust in it more than anything else we
need men who live by God confidence and
not selfconfidence we are in a spiritual
battle every day and you cannot let up
for even a second you need to put on the
armor of God and fight with truth
against all the love that is out there
in the world all the distractions and
you need to run your race until the end
to receive the crown of life but how can
you fight if you don't know the truth
God's word do you know his word do you
read it do you study it do you live it
do you use it as part of the armor of
God to fight back against the devil
because there are a lot of clever people
in this world who mixes the truth with
life it can even be 99% truth and 1% lie
and it can distract you it can deceive
you to go in the wrong direction you
know the devil when he tried to tempt
Jesus he used the
truth but he used it in the wrong way
and
Jesus Jesus didn't fall for his attacks
because Jesus is the word of God he
couldn't deceive
Jesus and what did Jesus do do to fight
back he quoted scripture every single
time and the Devil Couldn't fight with
that and that's why he
left and that's what you need to do as
well 2 Timothy 3:16 Says all scripture
is breathed out by God and profitable
for teaching for reproof for correction
and for training in righteousness that
the man of God may be complete
equipped for every good
work he didn't say some of scripture was
breathed out by God not 99% he said all
scripture was breathed out by God do you
understand how amazing this is the god
of the universe it is his word what he
chose to reveal to us he wants us to
know understand and live by his truth
man this is so
powerful and unfortunately a lot of
people today are being distracted by the
busyness of this world and the
devil and they don't study God's word
anymore so I want to plead with you
today to study God's word and to help
you to do that to fight all the battles
on this road of sanctification that you
are on I want to give you five crucial
important Bible verses that I believe
every man Christian man should know
let's start with the first one 1
Corinthians 16 verse 13 Be
watchful stand firm in the faith act
like men be strong let all that you do
be done in love man I love this
verse it says that we have to Be
watchful our are you are you always on
guard looking out because we are in a
battle whether you like it or not and
you need to Be watchful you need to be
careful you need to be on guard being
able to see when evil is attacking you
or your family you also need to be able
to discern to watch out there in the
world to see what darkness is doing and
then to shine your light to expose it
Ephesians 5:11 says take no part in the
unfruitful works of darkness but instead
expose
them and then verse 15 says look
carefully then how you walk not as
unwise but as wise making the best use
of the
time because the days are
evil so how do you do this
practically standing on guard being
watchful shining your light well right
after Paul says in 1 Corinthians
16 To Be watchful he says this stand
firm in the faith a lot of men today are
not doing this anymore they're like
jellow you know easily being distracted
easily being deceived because they don't
follow sound Doctrine
anymore Titus 2 verse one says but as
for you teach what Accords with sound
Doctrine
and 2 Timothy 1:13 says follow the
pattern of the sound words that you have
heard from me in the faith and love that
are in Christ
Jesus to live and teach sound Doctrine
you need to know the Bible do you or do
you just follow what is in at the moment
what is trending or listening to
preachers who preach to itching ears
just sharing motivational
messages there are many false teachers
out there who just
preach to people what they want to hear
what their fleshly Natures want to hear
and for a lot of churches is just a
business model they don't even preach
the gospel anymore what God wants them
to preach they're too scared to say
certain things because then people will
leave the church and take their money
with them and it is causing many
churches to be lukewarm because of half
truths and motivational
messages not preaching sound Doctrine
when I grew up the church was so
different even here in South Africa my
dad was a preacher he lived the way he
preached and I knew the fundamental
doctrines of scripture today if you ask
Christians about it they don't even know
let me ask you do you know the
fundamental doctrines of scripture or
even important things for example the
doctrine of man of
God of Christ and the Holy Spirit the
application of redemption in other words
what is
justification
sanctification
regeneration the New
Covenant how to live in the spirit and
important things like how to be a real
man a good
father
son and husband according to scripture
you see men are being attacked from all
sides these days with lies but how can
you know the lies if you do not know the
truth and it it saddens me to see that
so many men run after motivational
messages because that is what they want
but it cannot bring lasting change
because it is only the word of God that
can set you free God's word can change
you if you read it if you absorb it and
act on it which brings us to the next
Bible verse every Christian man should
know James 1 vers 22 but be doers of the
word and not hearers only deceiving
yourselves every man must decide if he
wants to follow Jesus the world or his
own
will if you want to be a true reborn
Christian you need to follow Jesus
Christ because he is the truth the word
of God John 1 vers1 in the beginning was
the word and the Word was with God and
the Word was God if you follow him if
you truly love Jesus Christ with
everything that is in you you will obey
his word John 14:15 says if you love me
you will keep my
Commandments please listen to me today
you cannot just follow certain parts of
scripture certain parts of the Bible
that fits in with your lifestyle and
leave the rest you either commit to God
fully and change your lifestyle
according to scripture or you're
deceiving yourself and you're a lukewarm
Christian which means you're a fake
Christian 2 Corinthians 10:5 says we
destroy arguments and every lofty
opinion raised against the knowledge of
God and take every thought captive to
obey by Christ being ready to punish
every Disobedience when your obedience
is
complete you see you take every thought
captive that's on your soul level your
own thoughts that comes with your
emotions your own will you take those
thoughts captive and you bring it under
the lordship of Jesus Christ that is
what it means to now live through the
spirit because it is the spirit that has
set you free from the law of sin and
death meaning if you live in the spirit
you will not sin you will obey God's
word not just all because you have to
but because you love him you become a
doer of God's word not just a hearer
deceiving yourself you read in 1 Peter
3:7 husbands live with your wives in an
understanding way showing honor to the
woman as the weaker vessel since they
are hirs with you of the grace of life
so that your prayers may not be
hindered so when you read this and you
realize because the Holy Spirit Will
convict you you realize man a few
minutes ago I wasn't really nice to my
wife I might I might have been right
what I said but the way I said it was
from the flesh you don't just brush it
off continue to read because oh you want
to spend our time with God you have
unrepented sin you need to stop reading
the Bible then there and then you stand
up you go to your wife and you say I'm
sorry forgive me the way that I talked
you was wrong and then after that you
come back to God's word continue the
Bible study John 14: 211 Whoever has my
Commandments and keep them he it is who
loves me and he who loves me Will Be
Loved by my father and I will love him
and manifest myself to him if you pray
to God and you're wondering why does God
not answer you why does he not talk to
you this might be it because you want to
practice religion from the flesh you
have unresolved sin in your life and you
haven't asked those people and God to
forgive you you are not taking the
unresolved sin in your life seriously
you need to break with sin and take it
seriously and that takes us to the next
verse James 4:1 17 so whoever knows the
right thing to do and fails to do it for
him it is
sin wow it cannot be more clear than
this you need to break with sin we know
and we understand that when we repented
when we became a reborn Christian when
God Justified us as righteous when we
became his child God forgave us for all
our sins but after that as we continue
to walk on the road of sanctification
through the Holy Spirit we need to walk
and live
holy because we need to be led by the
holy spirit so when we do fall in sin we
come back to the father and we say
father I have sinned I am sorry and then
our relationship is restored and we
continue the walk being under the New
Covenant means that we are under the law
of the spirit and that means we need to
obey the Holy Spirit obey God in
everything that we do Romans 8 ver1
there is therefore now no condemnation
for those who are in Christ Jesus for
the law of the spirit of life has set
you free in Christ Jesus from the law of
sin and
death what is sin in its Essence sin is
not obeying God it is not like a lot of
people still think it is just about
obeying the Ten Commandments from the
Old
Testament yeah we have to obey God's
laww but under the New Covenant it means
we are under the spirit which means we
need to obey God in everything that we
do meaning we are led by the spirit we
need to walk live act in the spirit the
moment we don't do that it means we are
disobeying God and we are acting in the
flesh and then we will bring forth sin
Galatians 5:16 says but I say walk by
the spirit and you will not gratify the
desires of the flesh for the desires of
the flesh are against the spirit and the
desires of the spirit are against the
flesh for these are opposed to each
other to keep you from doing the things
you want to do but if you are led by the
spirit you are not under the
law so if you live according to the
spirit it means you're under the spirit
you are being obedient to God's word
you're being obedient to God right then
you will not sin now let me be very
direct with you and let me ask you are
you still living in the flesh let's take
a look at some of the The Works of the
flesh verse 19 now the works of the
flesh are evident sexual
immorality
impurity
sensuality
idolatry sorcery
enmity
Strife
jealousy fits of
anger
rivalries
dissensions
divisions
Envy
drunkenness
orgies and things like these let's be
real there are men out there there who
are claiming to be Christian men but
they boast about how drunk they are
getting every week the girls they meet
and the suay Doom this is not the
Christian Life under the Holy Spirit you
might go to church on Sundays and claim
to be a Christian even say that you
you're a Christian from birth because
you grow up in a Christian home that
does not mean you are a
Christian if you truly came to Christ if
you had an encounter with the Living God
he changed you you are a new creation
his spirit is in you and will convict
you of that sin you will not continue to
live in it and not feel
anything you will feel terrible about it
tears will run down your face and you
will say God forgive me and you will not
want to do it again some people say
Daniel why are you so serious about it
because this is serious I'm saying this
with a lot of love but you need to
understand that it is serious because
your soul is at stake and a lot of you
who are watching this video might be on
the way to hell let's continue with the
verse drunkenness orgies and things like
these I warn you as I warned you before
and as I am also warning you guys
today please listen that those who do
such things will not inherit the kingdom
of
God I'm saying this to you because I
don't want you to deceive yourself like
I used to do I was a lukewarm Christian
I told a lot of people that I'm a
Christian but I
wasn't until the death of my second
brother and God opened my eyes to the
truth and I realized I'm a sinner I'm on
the way to hell and I reached out to him
and I said God please change me forgive
me make me a new creation so today I'm
asking you to be truthful to yourself
examine yourself to see whether you
truly are in the faith verse 22 then
says but the fruit of the spirit meaning
if you are a spiritually reborn
Christian you will have the Holy Spirit
in you then you will automatically
produce this
fruit
love
joy
peace
patience
kindness
goodness
faithfulness
gentleness self-control
against such things there is no law and
those who belong to Christ Jesus have
crucified the flesh with its passions
and
desires if we live by the spirit let us
also keep in step with the
spirit if you want to live in the spirit
keep in step with the spirit then you
need to deny yourself the fleshly life
and that brings us to to the next
verse Matthew
16:4 then Jesus told his disciples if
anyone would come after me let him deny
himself and take up his cross and follow
me following Christ does not just mean
oh I'll believe in in Jesus Christ just
so I can have my ticket into heaven but
you still continue to live exactly the
same there's no change in you no saying
you believe in Jesus Christ meant that
he revealed himself to you you accepted
him truly and he changed you you
repented of your sins you turned away
from who you were
180° change you were transformed by God
himself the God who spoke the whole
universe into existence if you truly
became a reborn Christian it is a
miracle you cannot change yourself it is
God who changed changes us so that we
will never be the same again 2
Corinthians
5:17 therefore if anyone is in Christ he
is a new creation the old has passed
away behold the new has
come you become spiritually alive and a
whole new spiritual World opens up to
you where God transformed how you think
feel live he transforms everything
because now you are something new
something different for those of you who
do not understand what I'm talking about
it's also almost like you are now a
super human because before you only had
your body with the five senses and only
your soul right your emotions your
intellect your own will but now you have
received a new spiritual nature God's
spirit he sealed you with his spirit and
that changes everything in you and this
is also where God starts to reveal to
you your identity in Christ you can only
have a relationship with God through the
spiritual nature and in truth because
God is spirit and he is the truth and
man when you start to understand is when
you start to walk within this truth and
you say Father Here I Am You Are The
Potter I Am The Clay take out everything
that is not right and show me who I
truly am who you made me to be and work
through me do your work through Me For
Your Glory not for my own if you come to
this point of complete surrender then
you start to understand that this is
exactly where God wants you before he
can truly use you for his glory Proverbs
3:5 trust in the Lord with all your
heart and do not lean on your own
understanding in all your ways
acknowledge Him and He will will make
straight your
paths when you come to this point and
you see God's will for your life daily
he starts to reveal it to you and you
start to understand what your purpose is
then you realize that all your plans LED
you nowhere and pale in comparison to
what God has in store for you because he
knows you better than you know
yourself he knows what you are capable
of and what you can accomplish in the
future this is where you Find meaning
and fulfillment while you live with eyes
fully fixed on Jesus where you find
peace and all spiritual blessings you
know when I talk to certain Christians
and I tell them we have already received
all spiritual blessings in Christ some
of them are like what what are those
because people do not read scripture
anymore they don't understand this being
a Christian is not just about finding
salvation it's about finding true life
life and meaning in Jesus Christ
Ephesians 1:3 says blessed be the God
and father of our Lord Jesus Christ who
has P end blessed us in Christ with
every spiritual blessing in the Heavenly
places man this is so special when you
reach this point you start to realize
man life is not about me at all it's
about Jesus and it has been about him
all along all the answers you search for
this world every everything is about
Jesus and all you ever really needed was
him to abide in him to truly understand
what that
means I am the vine you are the bronches
whoever abides in me and I in him he it
is that bears much fruit for apart from
me you can do
nothing if anyone does not abide in me
he is thrown away like a branch and
Withers and the branches are gathered
thrown into the fire and
burned if you abide in me and my words
abide in you ask whatever you wish and
it will be done for
you you start to understand that this is
what life is all about this is where you
find true joy and peace the things that
humankind search for for thousands of
years the answer was is and always will
be Jesus
Christ it's amazing to think that the
world was created through Jesus for
Jesus and that he sustains
everything and he is far beyond what we
can even try to comprehend with our
small three-b brains and still this God
chose to come to us to be a personal God
to show us who he is because he wants a
relationship with us in verse 11 Jesus
says these things I have spoken to you
that my joy may be in you and that your
joy may be full When You Reach this
point of truly abiding in Christ you
don't worry and have anxiety or stress
about the normal things that still
affect people
today you start to see the whole picture
of Life the devil this world can do
nothing to you because you are in Christ
the normal things that used to influence
you and that still influence other
people today do not influence you
anymore Let Me
Explain there are people who claim to be
Christians but they still live according
to their own will focused on the self
life living selfishly always having
issues and struggles complaining about
this complaining about that complaining
about
everything they say things like oh this
is just who I am so don't expect me to
change or this is my child and I will
raise him as I want to or it is my money
so I will do it as I want to or I'm not
going to forgive this person they need
to come to me or I am never WR wrong or
just do what I told you because I'm your
husband or I'm your father I I I so full
of Pride and God hates Pride you need to
come to the end of that eye to the end
of yourself that eye needs to be broken
by
Christ so that you can say like
Jesus in Luke
22:42 not my will but yours be
done you know all those things that you
feel so I I I about even the eye he has
given that to you he has given you life
he's given you a self-determining will
because he wants you to choose him out
of
love he wants you to put him first in
everything to say like Paul in Galatians
2:20 I have been crucified with Christ
it is no no longer I who live but Christ
who lives in me you know certain men
don't really have these issues because
they struggle with being a good father
or a good son or a good husband or they
struggle to be this or that because of
the the reasons they think it is because
of the self life that is why they
struggle when you deny yourself
including your past you sort it out with
God once and for all you repent ask him
to forgive everything he does he doesn't
even think about it anymore it makes you
a new creation you start to live in the
spirit you are a new
creation you need to understand what
that means it means that you are not the
same anymore you need to forgive
yourself you need to move on when you do
you start to live through the spirit and
you have true love in you unconditional
agape love because it is the love that
God has given to you through the spirit
the love that you now have for God and
for other people and that will help you
to be a good father a good husband a
good son a good everything because you
do it through the spirit now your new
nature and that takes us to the next
verse Matthew
7:12 so whatever you wish that others
would do to you do also to them for this
is the law and the prophets now many of
you know that this is also called the
Golden Rule and if you follow this
Golden Rule you will automatically also
obey most of the other laws for example
you won't kill someone because you don't
want someone to kill you you won't steal
something because you don't want someone
to steal from you you won't curse or
swear at someone because you don't want
someone to do that to you when you
receive the Agape Love from God through
the spirit that is in you you start to
truly love other people because it is
God that is helping you and loving
people through you that is how you are
able to be the light and start to look
so differently at other people realizing
that they are sinners right you don't
love the sin but you love them and you
want them to be safe you you start to
live a life that is
unselfish
selfless you realize that people love
them just as much as he loves you and
wants them to be saved that is why so
many mature Christians truly love other
people and want to help them and that
that is how you will live as well if
God's spirit is in you Philippians 2:3
says do nothing from selfish ambition or
conceit but in humility count others
more significant than
yourselves Let each of you look not only
to his own interests but also to the
interests of
others so many Christians out there are
are so selfish because they still live
according to their self life and it
causes a lot of
hurt unnecessary
hurt but if you live through the spirit
through God's love it changes everything
because then you actually start to put
yourself in their shoes and understand
how they feel about certain things my
wife if I were in her position what
would she need from me right
now
my
son if I were in his position how would
I want my father to speak to me you see
you start to look at things from their
perspective and then together with the
spirit in you that gives you the ability
to truly speak into their lives you
start to think and act differently
because you you first ask God how do you
want me to handle this situation what do
you want me to give to this person what
do they need from me right now it is not
about you at all anymore
because you love God's word and because
he is in you you start to obey verses
like these to think of others as more
significant than yourself not to live a
selfish life and you start to especially
take verses like these seriously 1
Timothy 5 ver8 but if anyone does not
provide for his relatives and especially
for members of his household he has
denied the faith and he is worse than an
[Music]
unbeliever 1 Peter 3:7
husbands live with your wives in an
understanding way showing honor to the
woman as the weaker vessel since they
are hes with you of the grace of life so
that your prayers may not be hindered
and Colossians 3: 211 fathers do not
provoke your children L they become
discouraged so you start with your
household you
lead with gentleness with love there are
too many Christian men out there who are
harsh too harsh with their kids too
legalistic and you're pushing them away
from
God how dare
you yes you need to teach the truth in
love and bring them to Christ you need
to be the example you need to be as
Jesus you need to follow in the
footsteps of Jesus and be to your family
as Christ is to the church
that is a huge responsibility but you
can do it through Christ that gives you
strength you need to follow God's will
for your
family and it doesn't matter how you
were brought up and you have excuses
like oh I didn't have a good example
like this or that well you have the most
perfect
example Jesus
himself and through the spirit you can
do it through the flesh we cannot we
will struggle
we need to learn to do it through the
spirit you can be a great father you can
be a great
son and you can be a great
husband but then there comes a point
where you you also understand he's not
just about your family but about
everyone God sends on your path even
people you don't like with your self
life Matthew 5:43 but you have heard
that it was said You shall love your
neighbor neighbor and hate your enemy
but I say to you love your enemies and
pray for those who persecute you so that
you may be sons of your father who is in
heaven for he makes his son rise on the
evil and on the good and sends reain on
the just and on the unjust for if you
love those who love you what reward do
you have do not even the tax collectors
do the same and if you greed only your
brother Brothers what more are you doing
than others do not even the Gentiles do
the
same do you understand if you only care
about your own family members then you
are just the same as unbelievers who
care about their family members and they
don't care about other people outside
their family they always just put their
family first and they will even murder
kill steal and bribe just to get ahead
for their own family and that's why we
have so
much suffer suffering in the world
because people commit terrible acts just
to try and help their own family but
they're willing to do those acts against
other people with other families but you
are supposed to be different you are a
true reborn Christian will look after
your own family but also care about
other people out
there you will want people to be saved
you will want to make disciples of all
people and All
Nations because God's love is in you
verse 48 you therefore must be perfect
as your heavenly father is
perfect now let me just pray for you
father I want to ask you to please bless
this person who is watching this video
please change
them create a fire within them for you
to truly follow you radical discipleship
to follow Jesus you no matter
the cost to truly love other people out
there as well please father bless
them use this video this sermon for your
glory
amen if you want to grow in Christ and
need a help please watch these videos
here and it will help
you God loves you and I love you too
bye